Hello, listener. My name is Jason. I will be one of three hosts. I'm an on-time host. You're going to have a couple of tardy hosts joining us soon. If not, you're just going to get me. Just a solo episode with me. I hope that's not your future. But until then, let me tell you a little bit about myself. I'm a Capricorn, Saj Moon. I love things sweetened with anything other than sugar. I've had addiction issues. I've got a handle on that, I think, unless you put something sweetened with sugar in front of me. It's a real trigger situation for me. I just go right down a hillside full of sin. Oh, just in time. Here are the idiots.
你好，听众朋友。我叫杰森。我将是三位主持人之一。我是一个很守时的主持人。一会就会有两位总爱迟到的主持人加入我们。如果没有，那就只有我了。只有我自己的单人单口。我希望那不是你们的未来。但在此之前，让我简单介绍一下我自己。我是摩羯座，射手座月亮。我喜欢加了糖以外任何甜味剂的东西。我曾有过毒瘾。我想我已经控制住了，除非你把加了糖的东西摆在我面前。对我来说，那真是一个极易复发的导火索。我会直接滑向充满罪恶的山坡。哦，来得正好。这群笨蛋来了。
Guys, welcome to smartless. Smart. Smart. The listener does not know this, but this is our second episode today that we're recording. So what did you guys do in between shows? I had a little egg sandwich. I had pasta. That I made myself, not an egg salad sandwich like Sean would have made.
伙计们，欢迎来到 SmartLess 秀。Smart。听众朋友们不知道，这是我们今天录制的第二集节目。那你们在两场节目之间都干了些什么？我吃了一个小鸡蛋三明治。我吃了意大利面。我自己做的，可不是肖恩会做的那种鸡蛋沙拉三明治。
You had an egg sandwich? Now, what was the bread? Was it actual bread? Not really. What was it? It was gluten-free bread. that you know I had to toast to within an inch of its life so it tasted decent and then I put a little fake butter on it and then the eggs on top of it okay okay hang on to that I'm pretty sure the eggs were real we had a conversation with our friend on a different episode of the about enjoying ourselves and stuff you know but I feel that but it isn't but that I enjoy it tastes great I enjoy it. I enjoy. Now, last night we went out for a family dinner to this
你吃了一个鸡蛋三明治？那，面包是什么？是真正的面包吗？不太算。那是什么？是无麸质面包。你知道我得把它烤得干透才行，这样吃起来才像点样子，然后我抹了一点假黄油，上面放了鸡蛋。好吧，好吧，等一下，我敢肯定鸡蛋是真的。我们在另一期节目中和我们的朋友聊过关于享受生活之类的事情，你知道的，但我觉得那是，但不是，但我很享受，味道很好，我很享受。我很享受。对了，昨晚我们去了一家家庭餐厅吃晚餐，
yummy little restaurant down the street that specializes in Italian food. So I ordered a nice big fat cheese pizza and I whiffed down more of that than probably I should have. And we had some pasta and I had in B.A. In B.H or in the valley? Down in Laurel Canyon. Oh, little potch. Yeah. Yeah. Little Pachanel. Oh, you went you went Pache, not Pach. No, I know, but I say Potch, you leave it off. That's how you know that you're legit. You leave it off. That's how we go.
那是街尽头一家很美味的小餐馆，主打意大利菜。所以我点了一个又大又厚的好吃芝士披萨，我狼吞虎咽吃掉的份量可能比我应该吃的要多。我们还吃了一些意大利面，我在... 在布伦特wood？在 B.H 还是在山谷？在劳雷尔峡谷那边。哦，小帕奇。对。对。小帕奇内尔。哦，你去的是帕奇，不是帕奇。不，我懂，但我叫它帕奇，你不发后面的音。这就是你正宗的标志。你不发后面的音。我们就是这样去的。
Hey, there's MAPE and she can't hear us. Yeah. Oh, wait. That was, Hi, Maple. That was Maple, yeah. She's over here.
嘿，那是梅普（Maple），她听不到我们说话。对。哦，等等。那是，嗨，梅普。那是梅普，对。她在这儿呢。
Are you guys going for dinner tonight together? We're going to go, no, we're going to go over to our friend's house and we're going to celebrate our friend, Sean, because he's... He had a birthday a while ago. Yeah. He had a birthday a while ago.
你们今晚要一起去吃晚饭吗？我们要去，不，我们要去朋友家，我们要庆祝我们的朋友肖恩，因为他……他不久前过生日。对。他不久前过生日。
And we... I wish I could be there with you guys. I know. I know. I'm going to be. miss you well well you know we'll face time you if you facetined in last week i'll face time i will face time again yeah face time in again i will i will this face you got to give it time for that does the rest of your body is the rest of your body is the rest of your body as dark as your face will
我们……我真希望我能和你们在一起。我知道。我知道。我会想念你的。好吧，好吧，你知道的，如果你上周打过 FaceTime 的话，我会打的，我会再打 FaceTime 的，对，再打一次 FaceTime，我会的，我会的，你得给这个留出时间，因为你的身体其余部分，你的身体其余部分，你的身体其余部分跟你的脸一样黑吗？
yeah yeah of course no i didn't ask to see it put your top back on i know that is a tan like nobody's ever seen it's really good so do you read though you said you read three books while you were there was it just for the bounce effect of the paper so you or do you enjoy reading It's the sun take over. What were the three books? Do you remember them? Were they all nonfiction? Were they all World War II books?
对，对，当然，不，我没要求看这个，把你的上衣穿回去。我知道那是个谁也没见过的美黑，真的很棒。所以你真的读书了吗？你刚说你在那里时读了三本书，是为了感受纸张反弹的效果，还是你真的喜欢读书？那是太阳在起作用。那三本书是什么？你还记得吗？它们都是非虚构类吗？都是第二次世界大战的书吗？
The Giving Tree? No. Again. I haven't finished my third, to be honest. What were the first two? Were they just airport fiction? Well, one of them is my dad's book, Being Fate. Which I finally read, which is amazing.
《爱心树》？没有。又来了。说实话，我的第三本还没看完。前两本是什么？都是机场畅销书吗？嗯，其中一本是我爸爸写的书，叫《成为命运》。我终于读完了，太棒了。
I'm so proud of my dad, Jim Arnett, who wrote a book during the pandemic. And he wrote this sort of fictionalized this novel based on history and got it published. on history and got it published. That's cool. Yeah, it's really cool. And honestly, I was reading it, I was just thinking the whole time, I'm like, I'm so, my dad did this.
我为我爸爸吉姆·阿内特（Jim Arnett）感到骄傲，他在疫情期间写了一本书。他写了一部这种基于历史的小说，并把它出版了。基于历史并出版了它。太酷了。对，真的很酷。说实话，我在读的时候，满脑子都在想，我真是，我爸太牛了，他竟然做成了这件事。
I'm so proud of my dad. Yeah. So it's called Bean Fate, and it's really, really good. This is about the bean farmers of Kalamongas? No, no, I think you're... It's a remake of the Bean War or something, right? The Milagro, the Milagro Beanfield War.
我为我爸爸感到骄傲。对。所以这本书叫《成为命运》，真的，真的很棒。这是讲卡拉蒙加斯（Kalamongas）的豆子农夫吗？不，不，我觉得你……这是对《豆子战争》或类似作品的翻拍，对吧？《米拉格罗豆田战争》。
That's it. Yeah, good for him. Because I don't think they really got it on the last one. so okay no it's about booze runners back you know prohibition style you know back in the day patch up in Saskatchewan in the Bronfman family etc so i did that and then i read the sympathizer have you guys read that no what is that i feel like i wrote it's uh it's written by um vietnamese american author uh vietnam win it's about the vietnam war uh and it's about the vietnam war and he he himself um is a Vietnamese origin. Descent. Descent and origin, and he came here when he was young. And so it just talks about
就是那个。对，真为他高兴。因为我觉得他们上一部并没有真正理解这一点。所以，好吧，不，这是关于当年的私酒贩子，你知道的，禁酒令时期的那种，你知道的，萨斯喀彻温省的帕奇以及布朗夫曼（Bronfman）家族等等，所以我读了那本，然后我读了《同情者》。你们读过没有？没有，那是什么？我觉得我写了……它是……它是由越南裔美国作家……阮越清（Viet Thanh Nguyen）写的，它是关于越战的……它是关于越战的，他本人……
the experience of, God, honestly, I couldn't have loved it more. But it's not just about that. It's just about such an unbelievable story of, I don't know, just a guy who led to complex life. And there were so many other colored pictures in it for me. Any pictures of him sympathizing with folks? So many incredible, incredible passages in the book. that just blew me away that I would have to read out loud. I'll check that out. Yeah. I'll bet you $1,000 that you don't.
是越南血统。血统。血统和出身，他很小的时候就来到了这里。所以它只是讲述了……天哪，说实话，我不能再更喜欢它了。但这不仅仅是关于那个。它只是关于这样一个令人难以置信的故事，我不知道，就是一个过着复杂生活的人的故事。对我来说，里面还有很多其他丰富多彩的画面。有什么他同情别人的画面吗？书中有太多太多不可思议的段落，
You won. Yep. Why? Now, how do you decide what you're going to read when you're on the beach there? Like, reading in the sun makes you want to... What I do is... Right?
让我惊叹不已，我不得不大声朗读出来。我去看看那个。好的。我跟你打赌 1,000 美元你不会去看。你赢了。是的。为什么？那么，你在海滩上时，是怎么决定要读什么书的？比如，在阳光下读书会让你想要……我是这样做的……对吧？
Sorry, then I just started... I'm now reading this Splendid in the Vial, which a lot of people have read. These are big books. The Sympathizer won the Pulitzer Prize. Reading in the sun, to me, it's like being trapped in a hot car with the wind
抱歉，然后我开始……我现在在读这本《轰炸之城的辉煌》（The Splendid and the Vile），很多人都读过。这些都是大部头。《同情者》获得了普利策奖。在我看来，在阳光下读书就像是被困在一辆车窗升起、卡住、破碎的炎热汽车里，
Windows rolled up, stuck, broken. I don't know when the driver's coming back, and I have a three-year-old screaming in my ear. Yeah. That's what reading on a hot beach sounds like to me. Really? Yeah, because I'm already sweating and I'm still. And I have to concentrate on, like, word?
我不知道司机什么时候回来，耳边还有一个三岁的孩子在尖叫。对。这就是在炎热的海滩上读书给我的感觉。真的吗？对，因为我已经在大汗淋漓了，而且我还得集中精力去读什么，字词？
Yeah. And I got the hard bounce off the paper. No, I can't do it. I got the sunglasses on, and now the sweats, dripping on the glasses. I got to keep wiping the glass. And I hear all the people having fun in the water. Yeah.
对。书页还直反光。不，我做不到。我戴着太阳镜，汗水直往眼镜上滴。我得不停地擦眼镜。我听到所有人都在水里玩得很开心。对。
It's I can't. You know what, though? I'm snacky. I get real hungry on the beach. You know what's amazing is our guest today. Great segue. Our guest today is so fun. I love her.
我真的不行。不过你知道吗？我很嘴馋。我在海滩上真的很容易饿。你知道最棒的是什么吗？我们今天的嘉宾。绝妙的过渡。我们今天的嘉宾太有趣了。我爱死她了。
She's like a big megastar. No big deal, whatever. Wait, I've got it. It's a woman. I've got it. She's been on one of the hottest primetime dramas in the last few decades. She's born and raised in the Bronx.
她就像一个超级巨星。没什么大不了的，随便啦。等等，我想到了。是个女的。我想到了。她在过去几十年里最火的黄金档剧集之一里演过。她出生在布朗克斯，并在那里长大。
She's a New Yorker through and through. This might give it away. At a young age, she performed with the award-winning. Tadda, youth theater teen group. She graduated college with a double major in anthropology and sociology. Clearly not the right point for her to do. Before winning an Emmy,
她是个地地道道的纽约人。这可能会泄露答案。她在很小的时候就和屡获殊荣的 TADA！青年戏剧少年团一起演出。她大学毕业，主修人类学和田野调查双学位。显然这不是她该做的。在她赢得艾美奖之前，
one of her earliest acting kids was, I got to ask her about this, a traveling sex education sketch group. Her last name is not only a U.S. state, but also an apple. Please welcome the beautiful and extremely talented, Carrie Washington. Carrie.
她最早的表演经历之一是——我得问问她这个——一个巡回性教育小品团。她的姓氏不仅是美国的一个州，还是一种水果。请欢迎美丽且极具才华的凯瑞·华盛顿（Kerry Washington）。凯瑞。
Hello, Carrie. Hi, you guys. Oh, let's get right into it. A traveling, what is it? A sex-ex-education sketch group. What is that? It was not sketchy, although we did sketches. We were, oh, my God, that's where we're starting.
你好，凯瑞。嗨，你们好。哦，我们直接切入正题吧。一个巡回的，什么来着？一个性教育小品团。那是什么？它一点也不色情，虽然我们演小品。我们是，哦，天哪，这就是我们的切入点吗？
Okay, I'm so nervous, by the way. I'm such a, I'm such a mega fan of the show, so I'm really excited and a little nervous. No, my. Listen, we're just hanging out. Yeah, you can already hear what idiots we are, right? Well, every episode, but that's why we love you. So, okay, so... Bring us up.
好吧，顺便说一句，我好紧张。我是这个节目的超级大粉丝，所以我既兴奋又有点紧张。不，我的。听着，我们就是随便聊聊。对，你已经听出我们有多白痴了吧，对吧？好吧，每一集都这样，但这就是我们爱你的原因。所以，好吧，那么……给我们讲讲吧。
I, when I was a high schooler, when I was a teenager, I worked for the Adolescent Health Center in New York City, at Mountside Hospital. And it was like the beginning of the AIDS epidemic, like late 80s, early 90s. And we used to, we wrote these sketches, these skits about safer sex issues and losing your virginity and drug abuse and LGBTQ rights.
我，当我还是个高中生，当我还是个青少年时，我为纽约市的青少年健康中心工作，在西奈山医院（Mount Sinai Hospital）。那正是艾滋病流行的初期，大约是 80 年代末、90 年代初。我们过去常常，我们写这些小品，关于安全性行为、失去童贞、滥用药物以及 LGBTQ 权利的小品。
And so it was like I like I find you attractive I find you attractive hold on let me get a condom What was like how do you ask your boyfriend to put a condom on or how do you put a condom on or how do you make that conversation sexy? Because all the research was like people have the information but the behavior change is not there so we used to write I'd love to hear the first few things I would too I would too by the way I've had God Carrie it's like you gave me a bat and you put me at the plate and I've just been standing here and you just been throwing softballs up and I'm doing all my best because I want to impress you don't look back don't because I don't want to be just a total dirt bag and I'm just like in... Be yourself, well, be yourself. It's hard. This is your space. I'm a guest in your house.
所以就像，我，我觉得你很有吸引力，我觉得你很有吸引力，等等，让我拿个安全套。就像，你如何要求你的男朋友戴安全套，或者你如何戴安全套，或者你如何让这种对话变得性感？因为所有的研究都表明，人们有相关信息，但行为并没有改变，所以我们过去常常写……我很想听听前几个段落。我也想听。我也想听。顺便说一句，天哪，凯瑞，就像你给了我一根球棒，把我放在了击球区，我一直站在那儿，而你一直在投直球，我一直在尽我最大的努力，因为我想给你留下好印象。别回头，别回头，因为我不想显得像个彻头彻尾的混蛋，我只是在……做你自己，好吧，做你自己。这很难。这是你的空间。我是你家里的客人。
Do you so. What was the draft that made it to the stage on how to put on a condom in a funny, funny way? Well, we used to teach kids how to put condoms on by using bananas. So that always got a laugh. But it was really more like... I mean, the first sketch I was allowed to do
那么。那个真正搬上舞台的、关于如何以一种滑稽有趣的方式戴安全套的草稿是什么样的？好吧，我们过去常常教孩子们如何用香蕉戴安全套。所以那总是能引起一阵笑声。但它其实更像……我是说，我被允许演的第一个小品，
was actually a scene about whether or not I was 13 when I started doing the show. So the only sketch they would let me do in the beginning was should I lose my virginity or not? And it was a whole sketch about like my really cute boyfriend who's kind of pressuring me and I don't know if I should or shouldn't. And then the cool part, and this was actually incredible acting training, was that we would, the problems of the show were unresolved
其实是一个关于我开始演这个节目时是不是 13 岁的场景。所以一开始他们只让我演一个关于我应不应该失去童贞的小品？这是一个完整的小品，讲的是我那个非常可爱、有点给我施加压力的男朋友，而我不知道我到底该不该。然后最酷的部分——这其实是不可思议的表演训练——就是我们会……节目的问题是悬而未决的，
and we would stay in character after the show. And the audience would like solve our problems. We would ask the audience for advice. So they would, like, be in conversation. Yeah, we stayed in character. Then doesn't that mean the show is still going? No, like, the show would end, and then we'd do a Q&A, but our Q&A would be in character. And sometimes I would be playing, like, more than one character,
我们在演出结束后还会保持角色状态。观众会来帮我们解决问题。我们会向观众征求建议。所以他们会，就像是在对话。对，我们保持着角色状态。那岂不是意味着演出还在继续？不，我是说，演出会结束，然后我们会进行问答环节，但我们的问答环节是保持着角色状态的。有时我会扮演，比如说，不止一个角色，
so I'd have, like, a baseball hat for the girl who wasn't sure she should lose her virginity, and then, like, a red scarf for the girl who was, like, needed to tell her brother to stop selling drugs. So we had all these different, like, you know, conflict issues, and I got to develop character backstory and learn to be spontaneous, and I found my yes and while doing sex education. What was this group that sounds somewhat charitable and, you know, altruistic? No, no, no, but it sounds like you're, like, doing great thing. I wish I was doing stuff at 13 that was going around and doing, you know, but doing shows. But doing shows for, like, hospitals, and you said this was, like, for...
所以我可能有一顶棒球帽，代表那个不确定自己该不该失去童贞的女孩，然后还有一条红围巾，代表那个需要告诉她哥哥不要再贩毒的女孩。所以我们有所有这些不同的，你知道的，冲突问题，我得以培养角色的背景故事并学会即兴发挥，我在做性教育的同时找到了我的“好的，而且”（Yes, and...）。这是一个什么组织，听起来有点像慈善机构，而且，你知道的，利他主义？不，不，不，但听起来你像是在做一件伟大的事。我真希望我 13 岁的时候也在到处做这种事，你知道的，去演演出。而且是为医院演演出，你刚才说这是为了……
Yeah, we performed at, like, schools and community centers. How did you get involved in that? That sounds like you were walking around with a bunch of very nice. nice people. I have great parents. I was really into acting and my mom had read that there were auditions for this
对，我们在学校和社区中心之类的演出。你是怎么加入进那个组织的？听起来你当时和一群非常善良的人一起走来走去。我父母很好。我非常喜欢表演，我妈妈读到说这里有试镜，
I had done children's theater with that company Tadda that was mentioned which is a company in Midtown and this was like for teenagers and my mom had seen an ad about it and my mother's an educator so she was like educational theater is a great thing and then I came home with all these pamphlets about like gonorrhea
我曾和前面提到那个位于中城（Midtown）的公司 TADA！一起做过儿童戏剧，这是针对青少年的，我妈妈看到了一则广告，而且我妈妈是个教育工作者，所以她觉得教育戏剧是一件很棒的事，然后我带着一堆关于淋病的宣传册回到家里，
and she was like what is this but I would love this see the one act on Conneria. You're like, don't worry about it. We're going to put a condom over a banana. It'll be all good. We're going to fix the world's problems one banana at a time.
她当时就说，这是什么？但我会喜欢这个的。看那个关于淋病的独幕剧。你就像在说，别担心。我们会把安全套套在香蕉上。一切都会好的。我们要用一根香蕉来拯救世界的问题。
A funny thing happened on the way to the theater. Exactly. Wait, Carrie, let's, I want to get this out of the... Okay, guys, I have kind of a long story. I was wondering if we were going to tell the story. We're going to do it. We're just going to get past it. Because how could we not do it? Should Will and I lay down?
去剧院的路上发生了一件趣事。没错。等等，凯瑞，我们，我想把这个说出来……好吧，伙计们，我有一个挺长的故事。我本来在想我们究竟要不要讲这个故事。我们要讲的。我们直接把它抛出来吧。因为怎么能不讲呢？威我和我要躺下来吗？
Yeah, no. I was shocked that you asked me to be your guest because I was like, there's no way we're not telling this story. Of course we're talking about it. With me being punked by Sean Hay. So these guys have no idea what I'm going to say. So it's like if you can hang in there for like two minutes, which is a long time, but it's a long story. Because here we go.
对，不用。我很震惊你邀请我做你的嘉宾，因为我当时想，我们绝对不可能不讲这个故事。我们当然要聊这个。关于我被肖恩·海斯（Sean Hayes）恶搞的事。所以这些家伙根本不知道我要说什么。所以就好像如果你能坚持个两分钟——这挺长的，但这个故事很长。因为我们要开始了。
It's one of the most embarrassing things that's ever happened to me. I was shooting a pilot last year and took a long email to carry, asking her to help me out and email me back. Let me jump in. Yes. loves me. It was that, but it was like from another famous person, so it was okay. And it was like somebody that I
这是我经历过最尴尬的事情之一。我去年在拍一部试播集，给凯瑞发了一封很长的邮件，请她帮个忙，然后她回了邮件。让我插一句。是的。爱我。是那样的，但它是从另一个名人那里发来的，所以没关系。而且那是一个我……
respect and admire. So I was like, oh my God, I was so moved. I was deeply moved. I meant every word. And then there was the ask at the bottom of it. Always. Always, right? So, but she emailed, she emailed me back, asked her for my number, said, I'd love to call you to chat more about it. Great.
尊敬和崇拜的人。所以我当时想，天哪，我太感动了。我深深地被打动了。我字字出自真心。然后邮件底部有求助请求。总是这样。总是这样，对吧？所以，但是她回了邮件，她回了邮件给我，向我要了我的电话号码，说，我很乐意打电话跟你多聊聊这件事。太棒了。
Fantastic, wonderful response. At the same time, I was guest hosting a few episodes of Jimmy Kimmel's show, and while there had befriended a producer named Aaron, Aaron Irwin, who's now a good friend. So one night on my way home from the shows, I got a text on my phone saying, I'm watching on Kimmel right now, and you're doing great.
太棒了，绝妙的回应。与此同时，我在吉米·坎摩尔（Jimmy Kimmel）的节目里客串主持了几集，在那期间结识了一位名叫亚伦的制作人，亚伦·欧文（Aaron Irwin），他现在是个好朋友。所以有一天我从节目现场回家的路上，手机上收到了一条短信，上面写着：我正在看坎摩尔的节目，你表现得太棒了。
And I was pleased by the message, but I was like, perplexed because I didn't recognize the number. And then I deduced that it was Aaron from Kimmel, who was maybe watching like a rough cut of the show because we just exchanged phone numbers as I left the studio, but I hadn't put her contact and go on my phone. So I pulled over and saved the number in my context. It's Aaron from Kimmel.
我对这条信息感到高兴，但我很困惑，因为我不认识这个号码。然后我推断那是来自坎摩尔的亚伦，他可能在看节目的粗剪版，因为我们刚离开演艺棚时交换了电话号码，但我还没把他的联系方式存到手机里。所以我把车停在路边，把这个号码存到了我的联系人里。是坎摩尔的亚伦。
I'm at home, cut to, I'm at home eagerly awaiting the call from Sean because this is my number one fan. I mean, my dad doesn't love me this much. And now I think I'm going to get a healing because somebody who loves me is going to get on the phone with me and it's going to change my life. And even though I'm going to say no to the ask, we're going to be friends forever. Right, perfect, right. Big load of junk food just to prop you up.
我到家了，接下来的画面是：我坐在家里，满怀期待地等待着肖恩的电话，因为这是我的头号粉丝。我是说，我爸都没这么爱我。现在我觉得我要被治愈了，因为一个爱我的人要给我打电话了，这将会改变我的人生。尽管我会拒绝那个请求，但我们会永远是朋友。没错，完美，没错。一大堆垃圾食品只是为了支撑你。
Perfect. All right, so the phone rings, I pick it up and say, hey, and I see it's Aaron from Kimmel. What's going on? Aaron says, hi, how are you? Your email is so sweet. I couldn't wait to talk. to you. And I said, email, what email? And Aaron says, the email I sent you. And I was like, I don't remember sending you an email. Are you sure? And that's when the tone shifted between us.
完美。好了，电话响了，我接起来说，嘿，我看到是坎摩尔的亚伦。怎么了？亚伦说，嗨，你好。你的邮件太甜了。我迫不及待地想跟你聊聊。我说，邮件？什么邮件？亚伦说，我发给你的邮件。我当时想，我不记得给你发过邮件啊。你确定吗？就在那时，我们之间的语气变了。
And I said, Aaron said, is this Sean? And I said, yeah, who's this? And Aaron says, you didn't send me an email with your number? And then I turned into a total asshole. And I go, I think you have the wrong number. Why don't you check that email and your contact? Then why don't you get back to me? And that's when Aaron was like, that's probably a good idea. So I go sit down. I hang up the phone and I turned to my husband and I'm like, I'm being fucking punked. Because Sean Hayes sent me the nicest email I've ever gotten in my life. I just got off the phone with him and he was such a jerk to me.
我说，亚伦说，这是肖恩吗？我说，对，你是谁？亚伦说，你没有发过带你电话号码的邮件给我吗？然后我变成了一个彻头彻尾的混蛋。我说，我想你打错电话了。你怎么不查查那封邮件和你的联系人？然后你怎么不回给我？就在那时，亚伦说，那可能是个好主意。于是我坐下来。我挂了电话，转头对我的丈夫说，我他妈被整蛊了。因为肖恩·海斯给我发了我一生中收到的最甜蜜的邮件。我刚刚才挂了他的电话，而他对我的态度却像个混蛋。
And he's acting like I made up the email. I was like shaking. I was so, I was like, why would somebody do that? Does he think I'm untalented? I was so upset. sit down and talk to my husband and I'm chatting I'm telling I just got the craziest phone call and at 15 minutes in the conversation with Scotty I did all the math and like a like a shot in a movie came zooming towards my face I go I jumped up and I screamed holy shit that was Carrie Washington
而且他表现得好像是我凭空捏造了那封邮件一样。我当时气得直哆嗦。我当时想，怎么会有人这样做？他觉得我没有才华吗？我太难过了。我坐下来跟我丈夫说话，我在聊天，我跟他说我刚接了一个最疯狂的电话，在和斯科蒂（Scotty）对话进行到 15 分钟时，我算清了所有的账，就像电影里一个镜头朝我的脸飞速拉近一样，我大叫一声，我跳起来尖叫道：操，那是凯瑞·华盛顿！
and credits yeah I texted you back immediately explained everything and went and asked beg for you to call me back and I answered the phone and you were laughing I was I couldn't stop laughing because I was really, like, I thought I was being pranked, and I was so relieved. It was so, so lovely. Wow. Oh, God, that was funny. My feelings were so hurt.
然后是演职员表。是的，我立刻给你回了短信，解释了一切，然后去求你给我回电话，我接起电话时你在笑。我当时笑得停不下来，因为我真的，就觉得自己被恶作剧了，我太如释重负了。这真是太、太美妙了。哇。哦，天哪，太搞笑了。我的心都碎了。
And I was like, oh, I'm being gaslit. Like, he's gaslighting me. You guys have this great, now this great, like shared history. Beautiful history. Are you jelly? You're jealous. A little bit jelly. Because we only met.
我当时想，哦，我被精神控制了。就像，他在对进行我气煤灯操控（Gaslight）。你们现在有了这个伟大的、这段伟大的共同历史。美好的历史。你嫉妒吗？你嫉妒了。有点嫉妒。因为我们只见过。
Well, we had our dinner. We had our dinner. We sat next to each other. We didn't know each other. You were there. Don't say whoa. You were there. You were across the table.
好吧，我们吃了晚饭。我们吃了晚饭。我们坐在一起。我们当时不认识。你在那儿。别说“哇”。你在那儿。你就在桌子对面。
Yeah, but I mean. When you guys worked for me, you know, you both of all worked for me as a producer. When we worked for me, when we did the Facts Life. Live in front of a studio. Wait, who was at this dinner? What are you talking about? Jason and Will were at a dinner. You know how we, when we did it, we had a cast dinner to kick off for our episode,
对，但我的意思是。当你们为我工作时，你知道的，你们所有人都曾为我当过制作人。当我们为我工作时，当我们演《一家人》（Facts of Life）的时候。等等，谁参加了这顿晚餐？你在说什么？杰森和威尔去吃晚饭了。你知道我们，当我们拍那个的时候，我们有一个演员晚饭来为我们的剧集拉开序幕，
which I wasn't a producer then, so I have not. Oh, that's right. You were produced on the set. That's right. But I produced in the next two. And so these gentlemen, I came to the cast dinner. Oh, we're talking about your sister for your sister. This makes me so happy.
我当时还不是制作人，所以我没有。哦，对。你是在片场当制作人。没错。但我为接下来的两集担任了制作人。所以这些绅士们，我去了演员晚饭。哦，我们是在说你妹妹的……为了你的妹妹。这让我太开心了。
I'm in the family. We, for Norman Lear's live in front of a studio audience, which all three of you have graced us and blessed us with your performances. And likewise, as you have. Yeah. And if it weren't for really active producers like you and Justin Thoreau, that show would not be moving at all. I do a lot more than Justin Thoreau.
我是一家人。我们，为了诺曼·利尔（Norman Lear）的《现场录制情景喜剧》（Live in Front of a Studio Audience），你们三位都曾光临并用你们的表演祝福了我们。同样，你们也一样。对。要不是像你和贾斯汀·塞洛克斯（Justin Theroux）这样非常活跃的制作人，那部节目根本无法推进。我做的工作可比贾斯汀·塞洛克斯多多了。
Let me tell you something. I just want to put that out there. Justin Thoreau, and he must be nominated for a, you know, Producers Guild Award this year. Because, I mean, this guy got in there. He rolls up his sleeves He would have rolled them out If he had any sleeves
我得跟你说实话。我只想把话挑明。贾斯汀·塞洛克斯，他今年一定得被提名为制片人协会奖（Producers Guild Award）。因为，我是说，这家伙太拼了。他卷起袖子。如果他有袖子的的话，他就会把袖子卷起来。
He would roll him up for sure What is it with your thing With people not having sleeves? No, just Justin Everybody wears them except him Yeah, every day of his life He has a cutoffer And by way, sometimes people
他绝对会卷起来的。你这人是怎么回事？老是盯着别人有没有袖子不放？不，只有贾斯汀。每个人都穿（带袖子的），除了他。对，他生命中的每一天。他都穿着无袖衫。顺便说一句，有时候人们
don't have them With the gym and stuff But not everybody just doesn't wear them Ever Even basketball players now Wear sort of like Under sort of long sleeve thing Over their cuff
不穿袖子是因为去健身房之类的。但不是每个人都像他那样永远不穿袖子。甚至连篮球运动员现在都穿那种长袖的打底衫。套在他们的袖口外面。
You know what usually deters people from going sleeveless Winter that usually gets people to pop into a sleeve or two. Not him. Or mosquito infestations. It doesn't matter to him. He's fearless that way.
你知道通常是什么在阻止人们穿无袖衫吗？冬天。那通常能让人穿上一两件有袖子的衣服。可他不会。或者蚊虫肆虐。这对他来说都不重要。他在这方面无所畏惧。
He's fearless that way. Yeah. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Kara, one thing I didn't know about you was, by the way, what a story we'll have for the rest of our life. The rest of our lives. But double major anthropology and sociology, why, if you knew at such a young age, you wanted to act, and have you utilized those, that degree?
他在这方面无所畏惧。对。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中来。凯瑞，我有一件关于你不知道的事是，顺便说一句，我们余生都会有这样一个故事。我们的余生。但你主修人类学和田野调查双学位，为什么，如果你在那么小的时候就知道自己想演戏，你利用过那些学位吗？
This is a great question. I, so it's actually a little more complicated into that, but that's the easy answer that I give people. I designed an interdisciplinary major called Performance Studies, and it was inspired by, it was based on the graduate programs at NYU and Northwestern. So it was like the study that performance plays in different societies and cultures, and and that's what interested me. But you have to, to design your own major,
这是个好问题。我，其实这背后要复杂一些，但那是我给别人的简单回答。我设计了一个跨学科专业，叫做表演研究（Performance Studies），它的灵感来源于——它是基于纽约大学（NYU）和西北大学（Northwestern）的研究生项目。所以它研究的是表演在不同社会和文化场所中发挥的作用，而这正是我感兴趣的。但你要，为了设计自己的专业，
you have to write this whole thesis and defend it because they want to just make sure you're not trying to get out of taking statistics. So I had to kind of really work with all these academic mentors and come up with this program and design a curriculum for myself. And yeah, I'm just,
你必须写整篇论文并进行答辩，因为他们想确保你不是为了逃避修统计学。所以我不得不和所有这些学术导师合作，想出这个项目并为自己设计了一套课程。是的，我只是，
I'm super interested in how we perform, like professionally, all of us, but also how we perform just in our everyday lives. And, yeah, I think I have used a lot of it. I mean, I think, you know, what we, for me, I tend to think about characters in the kind of social science context.
我对我们如何进行表演超级感兴趣，比如在专业上，我们所有人，还有我们在日常生活中如何表演。而且，是的，我觉得我用到了很多这方面的知识。我的意思是，我觉得，你知道的，我们，对我来说，我倾向于在社会科学的语境下去思考角色。
Like when I'm playing a character, I like to think about how she's become who she is and how she thinks and how she lives in the world and how society impacts who she is. So I do feel like I use some of my, I feel like such a nerd. I've been talking too long about this.
就像当我扮演一个角色时，我喜欢去思考她是如何变成今天的样子的，她是如何思考的，她是如何在这个世界上生活的，以及社会是如何影响她的身份的。所以我觉得我确实用到了我的一些……我觉得自己像个书呆子。关于这个我聊得太久了。
No, that's okay. I use some of my social science. I was going to talk about my character room that I have here and I go into my character room. And I've kept all that. All the costumes of my great characters, all my costumes. Yes, through the years. Wait, now, Carrie, I'm the dumbest of the four of us.
不，没关系。我用到了一些社会科学的知识。我本来想谈谈我在这里拥有的角色房，我会走进我的角色房。我把那些都保留了下来。我所有伟大角色的服装，我所有的服装。是的，这些年来。等等，凯瑞，我是我们四个人里面最笨的。
Will you define anthropology for me? Pause. Pause. He is. Go ahead. Anthropology is the study of society, yes? Sociology is more the study of society. Therego, the name. Yes. Anthropology is...
你能为我定义一下人类学吗？暂停。暂停。他是。请讲。人类学是对社会的研学，对吧？社会学更是对社会的研学。因此得名。是的。人类学是……
More about ants? Is this just about ants and the ant culture, right? I mean, no. It's more, it's more, um, anthropology is more indigenous cultures and, um, historical culture. So not present day society, but more the role of kind of how societies have evolved through time. Sociology would be the modern day version of anthropology. What's currently, what's currently happening? That's enough will.
更多关于蚂蚁的？这只是关于蚂蚁和蚂蚁文化的吗？我是说，不是。它更多的是，人类学更多的是关于土著文化和历史文化。所以不是当代社会，而是更多关于社会随时间演变的角色。社会学将是人类学的现代版。当前正在发生的事情是什么？够了，威尔。
That's enough will. And anthropology has a little more ritual, like study of ritual. Yeah. But it's also a fabulous story. See, there's my fellow dumb dumb, right there. Hi. I like an anthropologist. I like their stuff. Well, you'd like the sympathizer.
够了，威尔。人类学有更多的仪式感，比如对仪式的研究。是的。但这也是一个极好的故事。看，我的笨蛋同伴就在那儿。嗨。我喜欢人类学家。我喜欢他们的东西。好吧，你会喜欢《同情者》的。
It's a great book. Oh, hey. Actually, I'm kidding. Won the Pulitzer. Did you go, it did. Did you go to NYU? Is that what you were saying? No, no, no.
这是一本好书。哦，嘿。其实，我开玩笑的。获得了普利策奖。你去过，确实获得了。你去了纽约大学吗？你刚才是在说那个吗？不，不，不。
I look, they, those NYU and Northwestern were the schools that had graduate degrees in performance studies that I admired and was interested in. But I didn't actually want to go to graduate school, so I tried to just skip ahead and do it in undergrad. I went to GW, Gdub in D.C. Oh, okay. G-dub. G-dub. G-dub. Now, did you finish with a degree in anthropology and sociology?
听着，那些，纽约大学和西北大学是我所钦佩和感兴趣的、拥有表演研究研究生学位的学校。但我其实不想读研究生，所以我试图直接跳过，在本科阶段就完成它。我上了乔治华盛顿大学（GW），D.C. 的 G-dub。哦，好吧。G-dub。G-dub。G-dub。那你最终拿到人类学和田野调查的学位了吗？
I finished in a degree in performance studies. I got to actually, like, I wrote my own situation. Got it. I created my reality. Wow. Does anybody call you K-dub? Yes, especially because I went to G-dub. Yeah, people call you K-dub.
我拿到的是表演研究的学位。我实际上做到了，就像，我自己写了我的培养方案。明白了。我创造了自己的现实。哇。有没有人叫你 K-dub？是的，尤其是因为我上了 G-dub。对，人们叫你 K-dub。
Now, wait, are you the only one with a college degree on this chat? Yeah. Sean, what's your excuse? How far did you go? I went four years, and then I got an honorary degree. doctorate, but I never graduated. I got one of those, too. You just show up.
现在，等等，你是这个聊天里唯一一个拥有大学学位的人吗？对。肖恩，你有什么借口？你读到大几？我读了四年，然后我拿到了荣誉博士学位，但我从来没有真正毕业。我也拿到过那种。你只要出席就行。
I got one of those. Yeah, if you give a speech, they give you one. You can get one of those guys. Sean, I don't understand. You went for four years. How did you not, isn't that how long it takes? That's a great question. I was two or three courses shy, and I just did not have any more gas in me to go.
我也拿到过那种。对，如果你发表了演讲，他们就会给你一个。你们也能拿到那种。肖恩，我不明白。你读了四年。你怎么会没能，那不是需要花的时间吗？问得好。我只差两三门课程，而且我实在没有多余的精力去读完了。
I'm fascinated because you seem like a completer to me. I spent a lot of time with you and you seem to have a tremendous amount of gas. You got plenty of gas. I, I, I, especially with the amount of tuna saluting. Are you kidding with plain chips? And he lights the fuse with that glass of milk and off he goes. Nobody kills a bag of plain chips and a glass of 2% milk. Did you really drink a glass of milk?
我很着迷，因为在我看来你是个能把事情做完的人。我花了很多时间和你在一起，你似乎有惊人的精力。你有充足的精力。我，我，我，尤其是考虑到你吃金枪鱼沙拉的数量。你开玩笑吗，还配原味薯片？他还用那一杯牛奶点燃导火索，然后就开始了。没有人能干掉一包原味薯片和一杯 2% 的牛奶。你真的喝了一杯牛奶吗？
Is it real milk? Just like cows milk? Yeah, all every day. He's going to get in his Plymouth and drive off in a minute. But wait, Sean, so you ran out of gas two credits short. Will? How far did you get? Oh, I made it half a year.
是真牛奶吗？就像牛奶那样？对，天天如此。他马上就要坐上他的普利茅斯（Plymouth）汽车开走了。但等等，肖恩，所以你差两个学分就精疲力竭了。威尔？你读到了大几？哦，我读了半年。
Half of the first year. Yeah, that's right. Because college, to me, wasn't all just about the studies. It's about the social, it's about growing up, being on your own and, like, figuring stuff out. I had already been out of the house. You know, I went away to school first when I was 12. Now, I heard this story on the show about your clothes being taken to across town. That was different.
第一年的一半。对，没错。因为对我来说，大学不全是关于学习。它是关于社交，是关于成长，独立生活以及摸索事情。我已经离开家了。你知道的，我 12 岁就离家去上学了。现在，我在节目里听到过这样一个故事，说你的衣服被拿到了镇子另一头。那是不一样的。
I was like, that's kind of child abuse, no? Yeah. And then they made them plant trees and fix sewer pipes, too. Yeah, we did a lot of stuff. I mean, look, I didn't have a, it's not that bad. Believe me. But I was 12 when I left, so... Oh, you got a boge.
我当时觉得，这有点像虐待儿童吧？对。然后他们还让他们种树和修理下水道。对，我们做了很多事情。我是说，听着，我没有，没那么糟。相信我。但我离开时才 12 岁，所以……哦，你有个小插曲。
Someone's running around in your house. That's Emily. I know. Locations go to two. Guys. Emily's actually, she has listened to your show longer than I have. Hi, Emily. Hi, Emily.
有人在你的房子里跑来跑去。那是艾米丽（Emily）。我知道。地点转到二。伙计们。其实艾米丽听你们节目的时间比我还长。嗨，艾米丽。嗨，艾米丽。
They're saying hi. Hi, Emily. She's saying hi. I'm geeking. She's geeking out. When I was at dinner with you guys, when I was at dinner for the cast for live in front of a story, studio audience. I actually
他们在打招呼。嗨，艾米丽。她在打招呼。她在狂热追星。当我和你们一起吃晚饭时，当我参加《现场录制情景喜剧》的演员晚饭时。我其实
had not listened to a single episode yet. And I was embarrassed. And so I faked having listened to a few episodes. And I was able to do so effectively. She's got skills. She's a professional liar. I'm an actor. But I knew just from hearing
一集都还没听过。而且我很尴尬。所以我假装听过几集。而且我装得非常成功。她有两下子。她是个职业骗子。我是个演员。但我仅仅从听
Emily talk about it and also hearing my husband Namdi talk about it, I had enough context clues and like reference points to pretend that I had seen. But I hadn't. I hadn't watched. And listen. And so then I went home and felt bad, so I started listening. And then I was like, this is the best podcast episode.
艾米丽谈论它，以及听我丈夫南迪（Namdi）谈论它，我就有了足够的上下文线索和参考点来假装我看过。但我没有。我根本没看过。听着。然后我回家后觉得很糟糕，所以我开始听。接着我觉得，这是最棒的播客节目。
Jason, tell Carrie how much you love scandal every other. Yeah, I've seen as many episodes of scandal as you have seen of Arrested Development, Sean. Ooh, I have watched Ozark. Now, well, thank you. Now, what do you guys do about that? Because we all know a lot of people and are friends with a lot of people that do a lot of stuff. And you can't possibly see it also. You can't watch it all.
杰森，告诉凯瑞你有多爱《丑闻风暴》（Scandal），每一集都爱。对，我看过的《丑闻风暴》集数跟你看过《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）的集数一样多，肖恩。哦，我看过《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）。现在，谢谢你。那么，你们对这个怎么看？因为我们都知道很多人，也和很多人是朋友，他们做了很多事情。你不可能是每部都看。你不可能全都看完。
Yeah, do you feel bad about that? Do you lie about it? Do you make an effort? I'm just, I'm terrible about it. Well, I've just admitted that I lie sometimes, but I try not to. I mean, Carrie lies. I don't think you really lie. And now all her friends, it's out there, as they know,
对，你为此感到内疚吗？你会撒谎吗？你会为此付出努力吗？我嘛，我在这方面太差劲了。好吧，我刚才承认过我有时会撒谎，但我尽量不这样做。我是说，凯瑞会撒谎。我觉得你其实不怎么撒谎。现在她所有的朋友都知道了，
and she just lies, and that's fine. What I do is, you know, what's hard is, Sean, you know this one. It's like when you go, when somebody says, I'm doing, you know, I'm in a show on Broadway or I'm doing a play or whatever, I'm always reluctant to go because you have to go and say hi to the master. Well, now, Carrie, talk about that. Oh, yeah. I've changed Will since, since,
这事已经曝光了，她就是会撒谎，这倒也无所谓。我做的是，你知道的，难点在于，肖恩，你懂这个。就像当你去的时候，当某个人说，我正在做，你知道的，我在百老汇演一出戏或者我正在排一出话剧什么的，我总是很不情愿去，因为你必须去后台跟大师打招呼。好吧，现在，凯瑞，谈谈这个。哦，是的。自从……我们谈过之后，我对威尔的看法改变了。
We talked about that. Like, I know somebody, I won't say her name, very extremely, gigantically globally famous who came to one of my shows. And she didn't come back. And I was like, I get it. We don't really know each other. Why would she come back?
就像，我认识一个人，我不说她的名字，非常、极其、全球闻名，她来看了我的其中一场演出。但她没有来后台。当时我想，我懂。我们其实并不熟。她为什么要来后台？
It makes me spiral. When somebody doesn't come back, and maybe that just means I'm an insecure person, it freaks me out. No, but how do you know that they're there? Because that's the part that is. They tell you. So, listener, for...
这让我陷入抓狂。当有人不来后台时，也许这只是意味着我是一个缺乏安全感的人，这让我抓狂。不，但你怎么知道他们来了呢？因为那是让人纠结的部分。他们会告诉你。所以，听众朋友们……
The house manager tells you. So Tracy, when you're doing a show on, in New York. I think specifically in New York or is it in Chicago too, Shawnee. You end up finding out if there's anybody who has a sag card
剧场经理会告诉你。所以崔茜（Tracy），当你在纽约演一出戏时。我觉得特别是在纽约，或者在芝加哥也有，肖尼（Shawnie）。你最后总能发现观众席里有没有人拿着演员工会（SAG）的卡，
that's sitting in the audience and whether you've invited them or not. Sad card, Tracy's sidebar, Tracy, that's a screened actress girl card. Double Tracy's sidebar. So if they don't come back, you have to go back and say that you love the show, even if you don't
不管你有没有邀请他们。演员工会卡，崔茜的题外话，崔茜，那是美国演员工会卡。双重崔茜的题外话。所以如果他们不来后台，你就得去后台说你爱死这场演出，即使你根本
know the people in the cast. I just found that ritual to be weird. Well, that's what I mean. I don't want to lie, so I just, I'm like, I just end up not going to stuff because I'm what you're special. Because you don't want to go and not like what you see and then have to lie about it.
不认识剧组里的任何人。我只是觉得这个仪式感很诡异。好吧，这就是我的意思。我不想撒谎，所以我只是，我最后就干脆不去看不认识的东西了，因为我是那种特别的人。因为你不想去却又不喜欢你看到的，然后还得为此撒谎？
Oh, aren't you a person of integrity? No, I'm not. Can't you, but can't you go to a, to a show? I just don't want to get busted for life? Can't you go to a show without anybody knowing that you're there? I mean, like, who's clocking the audience? It depends on the show and the audience. Like, for me, I could never in my life
哦，难道你是个有节操的人？不，我不是。难道你就不能，难道你就不能去看一场演出？我只是不想被当场抓包。难道你就不能去看一场演出，而没有人知道你在那儿吗？我是说，谁会去统计观众是谁呢？这取决于演出和观众。比如，对我和我来说，我这辈子绝不可能
go to a show that has a black cast and not go backstage because they will know that I'm there. But wait a minute, you're saying if you were in a show and somebody in the audience has a sad card and doesn't come back, you take that personally?
去看一场由黑人演员主演的演出却不去后台，因为他们会知道我在那儿。等一下，你是说如果你在一出戏里，观众席里有人有演员工会卡却没有来后台，你会把这当作针对个人的事吗？
Yeah, there's an actor who I knew had come to see a play I was in called American Son and he did not come back stage and unbeknownst to him, I held it against him for like a year and a half. I was like, I just thought
是的，有个演员我知道他来看了我参演的一部叫《美国之子》（American Son）的舞台剧，但他没有来后台，而且他不知道的是，我记恨了他一年半。我当时想，我只是在想
how, like why? It was, you know, why? Why? Did you ever run into that actor and ask him? Well, I then found out because I'm friends with his wife that she was the only one who had come and that she was running straight to the airport afterward and that's why she texted me.
怎么会这样，像，为什么？那是，你知道，为什么？为什么？你有没有遇到过那个演员并问过他？好吧，后来我发现——因为我和他妻子是朋友——她是唯一一个来的人，而且她看完后得直接赶往机场，这就是为什么她给我发了短信。
And so I was like, oh my God, I've been like... He's been dead to me. Inside my heart snubbing him at parties. Yeah, he's been dead to me for a year and a half for no reason. You know what I'm going to start doing? I'm going to start going in a lot of theater and making a point of not going backstage. but hanging around outside a lot for a long time
所以我当时想，天哪，我一直在……他在我心里已经死了。我在派对上对他的冷落视而不见。是的，无缘无故地，他在我心里已经死了有一年半了。你知道我要开始做什么吗？我要开始频繁去看戏剧，并且特意不去后台。而是一直在外面晃荡很长时间，
and then leaving and then going like not only did he not come back but he fucking he didn't even run off he was here he was here for a while milling around what I learned in that is that I have to be more generous and I try to be more generous in my attitude toward people but that was a really good reminder of like you don't know what's going on in people's lives
然后离开，然后表现得像：不仅他没来后台，他妈的连走都没走，他在这儿，他在外面晃荡了好一会儿。我从那件事中学到的是，我必须变得更慷慨，我尽量在对待他人时保持更慷慨的态度，但这真的是一个很好的提醒，让你明白你根本不知道别人的生活里正在经历什么。
even if somebody really snubs you to your face you don't know if they just had a car accident or like it just was a reminder like be generous The world just does not revolve around you and your Broadway performance. But you seem constantly happy, sunny. You don't seem like a dark person. What would get the real ire up in you? When are you the nastiest?
即便有人真的当面给你难堪，你也不知道他们是不是刚遭遇了车祸，或者这只是个提醒——保持大度。世界并不是围着你和你的百老汇演出转的。但你好像一直都很快乐、阳光。你看起来不像是那种阴暗的人。什么事会真正激怒你？你什么时候最刻薄？
Finally we're going to meet the real carry-wash. No. Is it traffic? Is it people that cut you off in traffic? No, no. I'm not a traffic. Because I'm not a very good driver, so I have to be generous when I'm driving. What really pisses you off?
终于我们要见到真正的凯莉·华盛顿了。不。是交通拥堵吗？是路上强行变道插队的人吗？不，不。我不讨厌交通。因为我车技不太好，所以我开车时必须大度点。到底是什么事真把你惹火了？
You know what? Dishonesty. Like, to circle back, like, if I feel like I'm being gaslit or people are keeping information from me in that way. You know how, like, people really like to infantilize actors? Like, they don't want to talk to the talent. They don't want to tell talent things. Or, like, just in my life, throughout my life,
你知道是什么吗？不诚实。比如，绕回刚才的话题，如果我觉得自己被PUA了，或者有人故意对我隐瞒信息。你知道大家有多喜欢把演员当小孩子看待吗？比如，他们不想和有才华的演员交流。他们不想把事情告诉演员。或者，就像我生活中的那样，贯穿我的一生，
whether it's because of my acting or whatever. If I feel like people aren't being honest with me, it really upsets me. This is what makes you a good producer, right? Yeah, maybe. Somebody who's like holding the information and then sort of disseminates it throughout the production. You understand what a value that is and how bad it is when you're on the other side of that, not getting it. Carrie, by the way, I can relate to that.
不管是出于我的演艺生涯还是别的什么原因。如果我觉得人们对我不够坦诚，我就会非常难过。这就是为什么你能成为一个优秀的制片人，对吧？对，也许吧。那种掌握着信息，然后将其逐步透露给整个制作团队的人。你深知这种信息的价值，也深知当你身处另一端、被蒙在鼓里时会有多糟糕。凯莉，顺便说一句，我对此感同身受。
I'm like, tell it to me straight. Yeah. Just let me know. To me fucking straight and let me, I'll decide how I react. Right. By the way, honestly, Will, if you come to see me in something, like let's say accidentally, you stumble upon a play that I meant on Broadway. You don't know I'm in it.
我会觉得，有什么直说。对。直接告诉我。对我直言不讳，然后让我来，我自己决定怎么反应。没错。话说回来，老实说，威利，如果你来看我的演出，比如说不小心，你偶然撞见了一部我在百老汇演出的戏剧。你不知道我在里面。
Yeah, yeah. If you came backstage and you said, I'm not crazy about this one. It would make me feel closer to you than you leaving. And I appreciate the transparency. I'm making this pledge to you today. You're going to tell me when I suck.
对，对。如果你走到后台对我说，我对这部戏不太感冒。这会让我觉得跟你更亲近，而不是你直接离开。我很感激这份坦诚。我今天向你保证。只要我演砸了，你就要告诉我。
I will always be honest with you. I will always be straight up with you about what I think about where you're at. And I want you to do it. And forget, in performance, on stage and in your life. Okay? This is amazing. I'm so low.
我一定会对你坦诚相待。我对你的现状有何看法，也一定会对你直言不讳。我希望你也这样对我。而且不仅是在表演中、舞台上，在生活中也是如此。好吗？这太棒了。我太低落了。
Very, the worst thing, wait, really quick, the worst thing anybody could ever say when they come backstage, boy, it looks like you're having a lot of fun up there. That's the kiss of death. That is the worst. Or like, or the like, you guys did that. That was, you did, wow, you did that. You do this how many times a week? Yeah.
最糟糕的，等等，说真的，大家来到后台时能说出的最糟糕的话就是，天哪，看起来你在上面玩得很开心啊。那是致命的一击。那绝对是最糟糕的。或者诸如，或者像，你们居然做到了。那是，你做到了，哇，你居然做到了。你一周要演这么多场吗？对。
Well, that's the thing, too, is it's so, you're so vulnerable. When you're on stage, you're so, there's no edit room, there's no score to hide the moment that wasn't fully honest. Like, you're just so vulnerable up there. So I think that's probably why I was also, like, a little more raw than usual. Yes, yes. Now, in the world of not being told everything
嗯，这就是问题所在，实在是，你太脆弱了。在舞台上时，你是如此地，没有剪辑室，没有配乐来掩饰那些不够真诚的瞬间。就像，你在台上面对观众是毫无保留的。所以我猜这大概就是为什么我也，比平时要更情绪外露、更敏感一点。对，对。话说回来，在那些信息并非事事都被告知的行业里，
that maybe they should be told, in the world of series television, Tracy, oftentimes actors will not be told how that particular season is going to end. Now, you're a producer on that show, so you probably have more access to storylines. But have you had that instance with the headwriter about, you know,
也许有些事本该告诉他们，在电视连续剧的世界里，崔西，演员们往往不会被告知那一季将如何收场。现在，你是那部剧的制片人，所以你可能更容易接触到剧情线。但你有没有遇到过这种情况：和首席编剧沟通时，你知道的，
Let me know what my finish line is as an actor so I can calibrate what the arc is to get there instead of waiting to read each episode, you know, piecemeal. Yeah, I was not a producer in the beginning of Scandal. I became a producer later on in the life of the show. And director. Yes, and director. And, but my favorite example of not knowing was we had a guest star named Joe Morton. And Joe Morton is an actor.
作为一名演员，请告诉我我的终点线在哪里，这样我就可以调整故事走向的弧光，而不是等着一集一集地零星读剧本，你知道的。对，在《丑闻》刚开始的时候我不是制片人。我是后来在这部剧播到中后期时才成为制片人的。还是导演。对，也是导演。但是，对于“被蒙在鼓里”这件事，我最喜欢的例子是，我们曾有一个客串明星叫乔·莫顿。而乔·莫顿是一位演员，
I'm a huge fan of. He did an incredible John Sayles film called Brother from Another Planet. Oh, I love Joe Morton. He's so good. So he's a stellar. And he came on, he was like the one guest star that came on our show that I called home to mom and dad and was like, oh, my God, Joe Morton's on the show. And I was never in scenes with him.
我是他的超级粉丝。他拍过一部非常棒的约翰·塞尔斯导演的电影，叫《来自另一个星球的兄弟》。哦，我太喜欢乔·莫顿了。他太棒了。所以他是一位大咖。他来客串时，他是我们剧组唯一一个让我打电话向我爸妈炫耀的客串演员，我说：“天哪，乔·莫顿来我们剧组了。”而且我和他从来没有对手戏。
He was always in scenes with these other characters on the show. And every table read, I'd be like, God, I really hope that we can do a scene together. And he'd be like, me too, me too. And I knew that he had been in talks to do Romeo and Juliet on Broadway. And he had dropped out of that to come to do scandals. And I was like, he doesn't even get any scenes with number one. Like, why did he drop out of this play on Broadway? He's got no scenes with me.
他总是和剧里其他角色有对手戏。每次剧本围读时，我都想：“天哪，我真希望我们能有一场对手戏。”他就会说：“我也是，我也是。”我知道他当时在洽谈出演百老汇的《罗密欧与朱丽叶》。他为了来拍《丑闻》而推掉了那部话剧。当时我就想：“他甚至连跟主角的一场对手戏都没有。他为什么要推掉百老汇的那部话剧？他跟我一场对手戏都没有。”
Like, why do you do that? And I just was super like, what's going on? At the end of the scene, the very final line of that season was I get in a car. Joe Morton is sitting across from me. And he says hi. And I say, with a question mark at the end, dad? Because he was my father on the show. And he knew from the beginning, from his first phone call with Shonda Rimes, he knew that he was going to be my dad.
“他为什么要这么做？”我当时真的超纳闷，“这到底是怎么回事？”直到那场戏结束时，那一季的最后一句台词是我上了车。乔·莫顿坐在我的对面。他说了一声“嗨”。而我带着一个问号说：“爸爸？”因为他在剧里演我的父亲。从一开始，从他与珊达·莱梅斯的第一次电话沟通起，他就知道自己要演我的父亲。
And I didn't know, I didn't know until our table read of that episode, like live in the room with everybody. It was incredible. Yeah, so wonderful. But it would have been cool if they'd pulled like a Star Wars and didn't tell you until you were actually filming the scene. Right? That would have been amazing. Is that how it happened in the scene? Yeah, Empire Strikes Back.
而我根本不知道，直到我们围读那一集的剧本时——在房间里和大家一起现场对词时，我才知道。这太不可思议了。是的，太棒了。但如果他们能搞一个像《星球大战》那样的恶作剧，直到你们真正拍摄那场戏之前都不告诉你，那不是也很酷吗？对吧？那绝对太神了。拍那场戏的时候真的是那样的吗？对，在《帝国反击战》里。
Well, do you mean in the movie, but not on set, right? No, on the set. Darth Vader just blurbed something else. And then in post, they put, you are my, you are. Luke, I am your father. No. So that the crew didn't know nobody knew
哦，你是说在电影里，但不是在片场，对吧？不，在片场。达斯·维达随口胡诌了另一句台词。然后在后期制作时，他们配上了：你是我的，你是。卢克，我就是你父亲。不。所以剧组的人都不知道，没有人知道，
until the movie came out. Right. And I think... Mark Hamel knew? Yeah. Wow. Isn't that wild? They were trying to protect
直到电影上映。对吧。而且我认为……马克·哈米尔知道吗？对。哇。是不是很疯狂？他们当时是为了防止
the crew from leaking that to the fan base. Yeah. I think that's what I'm so. Hey, Sean, any more great tidbits from the winter circle? From 70 years ago? Also...
剧组人员把这个秘密泄露给粉丝群体。对。我想这就是为什么我这么……嘿，肖恩，冬日圈子里还有什么来自70年前的精彩八卦吗？还有……
What about Chris Pines? What are you doing? Audition process for Star Trek. Let's bring Scotty in. Give us some light on that. And do you know that the bridge on the enterprise actually wasn't a bridge at all? Was scandal the first thing that kind of changed your trajectory? Or was it something else that made people really take notice?
克里斯·派恩呢？你在干什么？《星际迷航》的试镜过程。把斯科蒂请进来吧。给我们讲讲内幕。你知道进取号上的舰桥其实根本不是舰桥吗？《丑闻》是那种改变了你人生轨迹的作品吗？还是其他什么作品让人们真正开始注意到你？
Or do you think that that's the thing that really launched you? That was the thing. I mean, I had a really great film career before that because I had been in these Oscar-nominated films. I had a joke that if you hired me to play your wife, you would win an Oscar. because I was with Jamie Fox in Ray, and I was in Last King of Scotland with Forrest Whitaker. And so I had done, but nobody connected that the girl from Save the Last Dance was the girl from Ray, was the girl. Like, I was kind of a character actor and it was sort of disappearing into these, you know, really fun, very different films with accents from all over the world. And, but TV is just different, especially before streaming, right?
或者你认为那才是真正让你名声大噪的作品？就是那部。我是说，在那之前我其实有非常棒的电影生涯，因为我演过那些获得奥斯卡提名的电影。我曾开玩笑说，如果你雇我演你的妻子，你就能赢得奥斯卡。因为我和杰米·福克斯一起演了《灵魂歌王》，我还和森林·惠特克一起演了《苏格兰末代独裁》。所以我也拍过这些作品，但没有人把《留住最后一支舞》里的那个女孩和《灵魂歌王》里的女孩联系起来，觉得她们是同一个人。我当时有点像是个性格演员，就这样隐身于这些，你知道的，非常有趣、风格迥异的电影中，操着来自世界各地的口音。但是电视就是不一样，特别是在流媒体时代之前，对吧？
Like, TV was a different beast where all of a sudden I was in people's living rooms every single week. like how many people do you have in your life that you actually spend an hour with every week other than your shrink? Not a lot. So it's a very intimate relationship. Oh, she's talking to you, Sean, maybe. I'm talking to myself and myself.
就像，电视是一个完全不同的领域，突然之间我每个星期都出现在人们的客厅里。就像你生活中除了心理医生之外，还有多少人是你每周真的会花一个小时去陪伴的？没有几个。所以这是一种非常亲密的联系。哦，她可能是在对你说话，肖恩。我在跟自己说话，还有我内心深处的自己。
So it did, it definitely changed my, like I changed, you know, sort of the level of how I walked in the world maybe or like level of fame or whatever you're saying. Yeah, and were you scared to step in a role of leadership like that or was it finally like, was it like finally, oh my God, this is like what I've been waiting for to be, like the number one on the call sheet kind of thing? No, I really there was all this pressure
所以它确实改变了，我的生活确实变了，你知道的，就像我走在世界上的底气或知名度之类的水平发生了变化，不管你怎么说。对，你当时害怕踏入那种领导角色吗？还是说终于有一种，终于有一种“天哪，这正是我一直等待的，成为通告单上排名第一的主演”的感觉？不，我真的，当时有各种各样的压力，
because at the time there was all this talk. Every interview was about the fact that in almost 40 years there had not been a black woman as the lead of a network drama. Every article in the beginning. And I was like 37 or something at the time. So in my lifetime, I had never seen a black woman
因为当时到处都在议论纷纷。每一次采访都在讨论这样一个事实：在将近40年的时间里，竟然没有一个黑人女性担任过电视网黄金档剧集的第一主角。一开始的每一篇文章都在说这个。而当时我大概37岁左右。所以在我有生之年，我从来没见过哪个黑人女性
as the lead of a network drama. And so that's all my pressure was my fear of like if I saw, screw this up, they're not going to let another woman of color be the lead of a network drama for another 40 years. Like, I knew that we had to get it right and I just had to work as hard as I'd ever worked on anything
能担任电视网黄金档剧集的主演。所以我的所有压力都来自于我的恐惧：如果我把这事搞砸了，他们可能在未来的40年里都不会再让另一个有色人种女性担任电视网剧集的第一主角了。所以，我知道我们必须把这部剧做好，我必须付出我一生中从未有过的最大努力去做好每一件事。
in my life. But luckily, I've worked with amazing number ones. Like, Jamie Fox is the best number one in the business. No offense to you other number ones on here, but he's just the king. No one's better than Jamie Fox. Django, Ray, like having worked with him in those, he's just a, he's
但幸运的是，我合作过非常棒的第一主角。比如，杰米·福克斯就是业内最棒的第一主角。无意冒犯在座的各位其他第一主角，但他绝对是王者。没有人比杰米·福克斯更棒了。《被解救的姜戈》、《灵魂歌王》，和他在这些作品中合作过，他真的是一个，他
so generous. He's a team leader. He's a coach. He's a cheerleader he's everybody's dad and so you picked you picked stuff from him and like yeah i tried to collect like forest whittaker's a beautiful number one julia styles was an incredible number one like i just tried to remember the things that i admired about the leaders the good leaders yeah she's so great oh my god jingo and chain is one of my favorite movies of all time you were incredible unbelievable in that and i've seen it so many times it's it's always quentin has um quentin tarentino has is great at the uh theme of revenge right
太慷慨了。他是个团队领袖。他是个教练。他是个啦啦队员，他是每个人的老父亲，所以你从他身上学到了很多东西，就像，是的，我试着去吸收——森林·惠特克是个极好的第一主角，朱丽娅·斯蒂尔斯是个了不起的第一主角——我只是试着记住那些我所钦佩的领袖们身上的特质，那些优秀的领袖，对。她太棒了，天哪，《被解救的姜戈》是我有史以来最喜欢的电影之一。你在里面太棒了，令人难以置信，我看了好多次，它总是昆汀有……昆汀·塔伦蒂诺非常擅长复仇这个主题，对吧？
And that scene, I watch, whenever I watch that movie, it's disturbing to see you, that character, it's so disturbing. Any kind of fun Quentin stories? I mean, I love that he inserted himself in there in that one scene. It was so fantastic. Wait, which one? I forget. Django and Shend. I got a call.
而那场戏，每当我重温那部电影时，看到你、那个角色时，都会感到很不舒服，真的非常不安。有没有什么有趣的昆汀幕后故事？我是说，我很喜欢他在那场戏里亲自客串了一把。太棒了。等等，哪一场？我给忘了。《被解救的姜戈》。我接到一个电话。
I was asleep in my apartment in New Orleans. We were like halfway through filming, and I got a call at like two or three in the morning. And I pick up the phone. It's like, ooh, it's like, I was like, hello? And I hear Leo DiCaprio and Jamie Fox being like, yo! We need to talk. And I was like, what's happening? And they were like, Quinn wants to be in the movie.
当时我在新奥尔良的公寓里睡觉。我们拍摄进度差不多过半了，我在凌晨两三点左右接到一个电话。我接起电话。对方是，哦，就像是，我说：“喂？”我听到莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥和杰米·福克斯在说：“嘿！我们得聊聊。”我当时就想：“发生什么事了？”他们说：“昆汀想在电影里演个角色。”
I was like, what? So that like unfolded in the middle of shooting. Really? We were all shocked. But it was great. He was great. Yeah, so Jay just reminded you in the movie, he intercepts like the transfer of the of the collected slaves, right?
我当时想：“什么？”所以这事儿竟然是在拍摄中期突然冒出来的。真的吗？我们当时都惊呆了。但真的很棒。他演得很好。对，杰就在电影里提醒过你，他拦截了……搜集到的奴隶的转移，对吧？
Yeah. And freeze them or something. I can't remember. I'm so bad about remembering movies. I swear I got to get to. I can see a movie last week and forget the entire thing. Same. Same.
对。然后把他们释放了还是怎么的。我记不清了。我这人记电影情节太差了。我发誓我得去……我上周才看了一部电影，结果把整部电影的内容全忘光了。我也是。我也是。
Even movies I've been in. I don't remember movies I've been in. I don't remember lines. I like to think it's for a positive reason that like maybe we're so good about getting completely inside that world that once you leave that world, it stays over there. I don't know. That's a glass half fall. Yeah, it's kind of like in memento, like how he forgets like the neck, you know what I mean?
甚至连我自己演过的电影我都不记得。我不记得自己演过哪些电影。我不记得台词。我愿意相信这是一个积极的原因，也许是因为我们全身心投入到了那个世界里，一旦你离开了那个世界，它就永远留在那边了。我不知道。这算是一种盲目乐观吧。对，这有点像《记忆碎片》里那种，他是怎么把接下来的事情给忘光的，你知道我的意思吗？
Do you have an easy time memorizing lines though? Yeah. Jason does. Jason's unbelievable. And do they stay with you? Or do you forget them? No, I can drop them just as easily as I learned them. But like it seems like all my memory skills
不过你背台词容易吗？容易。杰森很容易。杰森简直强得不可思议。那台词会留在你脑子里吗？还是你转头就忘？不，我忘得跟我记的时候一样快。不过感觉我所有的记忆力
have just been channeled into that one very narrow lane. It's not great. Yeah. And now, a word from our sponsor. And now, back to the show. Kare, what, if I had, if I answered you, I mean, if I asked you this question and you had to think of something really, really fast,
好像全都倾注到这一个非常狭窄的领域里了。这可真不算什么好事。好了，现在插播一条广告。广告过后，节目马上回来。凯莉，如果我有，如果我问你这个问题，而你必须立刻马上想出一个人选，
who's one or two? of your favorite actors of all time that you worked with? Merrill Streep and... Controversial. Yeah. Well, I'm being honest.
你合作过的一生中最喜欢的演员有一两个是谁？梅丽尔·斯特里普，还有……有争议。对。好吧，我很诚实。
Not a lot of people agree with you on that whole talent assessment thing. What TikToks have she in? Have you seen her on a TikTok? What TikToks have she been on? And I mean, it's hard. There's so many. You can't top Jamie Fox.
没多少人会在那个“才华评估”的事情上同意你的看法。她拍过什么TikTok视频吗？你看到她在TikTok上发过视频吗？她上过哪些TikTok？我是说，这很难选。人太多了。你没法超越杰米·福克斯。
I love that that was the first one. And Jamie. I love Jamie. Yeah. Yeah, I just love him. What was your first paid acting gig? My first paid acting gig, I played a cheerleader. I don't think I had a name.
我很高兴那是你的第一人选。还有杰米。我太喜欢杰米了。对，对，我就是超爱他。你第一份有报酬的表演工作是什么？我第一份有报酬的表演工作是演一个啦啦队员。我想我当时甚至没有名字。
I think I was like cheerleader number two in an ABC after-school special. Yes. Called My Special Angel. Oh, wow. I think. Who was the angel? I don't know.
我觉得我在一档ABC课后特辑里演拉拉队员二号。对。那部剧叫《我的特殊天使》。哦，哇。我想是的。谁是天使？我不知道。
I don't remember. I may have done a PSA or something before that. God, after-school specials. After-school special. Jason, did you ever do one, an after-school special? I don't know if I did an after-school special. I did a few movies of the week. Those were good.
我不记得了。在那之前我可能拍过什么公益广告之类。天哪，课后特辑。课后特辑。杰森，你拍过那种课后特辑吗？我不知道我有没有拍过课后特辑。我拍过几部周播电影。那些挺不错的。
Remember they used to be a... CBS, NBC, ABC, they all used to make their own movies and they'd run Sunday night. Yeah, yeah. Now it's like Hallmark Channel does those in Lifetime. That's right. Wait, so, Carrie, and the other thing that I went on and on about before, but I'm going to do it again because you're so amazing,
还记得以前……CBS、NBC、ABC，他们过去都会制作自己的电影，然后在周日晚上播出。对，对。现在大概就是制片人频道和Lifetime电视台在拍那种了。没错。等等，所以，凯莉，还有我刚才喋喋不休说个不停的那件事，但我还要再吹捧一次，因为你实在太棒了，
was American Sun on Broadway, which I didn't get to see because I was doing something. But I elated to see it on Netflix. So, first of all, it was such an ingenious idea. to film the play like that? It was like, it was like a hybrid of stage in film. I'd never seen anything like it. Your performance was off the chart.
就是百老汇的《美国之子》，我当时因为有别的安排没能去看现场。但我很高兴能在网飞（Netflix）上看到它。首先，这个主意简直太绝了：把舞台剧拍成那样？这简直就像是舞台剧和电影的结合体。我从没见过类似的作品。你的表演简直突破天际。
Like, it was amazing. Wait, you're allowed to do that? You can film a play on Broadway? No, it was... No. We, like, so really the reason I came up with that idea was because I... I never seen anything like it. I love producing. I fell in love with producing at Scandal.
就像，太惊艳了。等等，你们可以这么做吗？你可以把百老汇的话剧拍成电影？不，那是……不。我们，其实我之所以想出这个主意，是因为我……我从未见过这样的作品。我热爱制片。我在拍《丑闻》时爱上了制片工作。
And the first film I produced was a film called Confirmation for HBO, where I played Anita Hill. And then I fell in love with it. And so they came to me to do this play on Broadway. producers. And I said, sure, I'll be in it if I can help produce. But on Broadway, producing really just means finding money. Like, you get to be a creative producer as well. But I was like, oh, I don't do the financing thing. I haven't done that. But I was like, okay, I'll jump in and I'll try. And one of the ideas I had for how I could make the money to help produce the
我制作的第一部电影是为HBO制作的一部名为《确认》的电影，我在里面饰演安妮塔·希尔。从那以后我就深深爱上了制片。所以后来他们找我来百老汇演这部话剧。制作人们。我说：“行啊，如果我能参与制片的话，我就演。”但在百老汇，制片其实主要意味着找资金。不过你也能成为一名创意制片人。但我当时想：“哦，我可不搞融资那一套。我没干过这个。”不过后来我想：“好吧，我来试试看，我加入。”为了筹集制作那部话剧的资金，我当时想到的方法之一就是：
play was like, what if we film it? What if we can sell it to a streamer, sell the rights? Such a great idea. Netflix, you know, Ted read it and loved it. But Jay, it was filmed, not in a proscenium. It was filmed. We built us on stages. We built on stages. We kind of like built a fourth wall to complete the room
如果我们把它拍成电影呢？如果我们把它卖给流媒体平台，把版权卖掉呢？真是个绝妙的主意。网飞，你知道的，泰德看过剧本后非常喜欢。但是，杰，它不是在镜框式舞台上拍摄的。它是被拍摄的。我们在摄影棚里搭建了布景。我们在摄影棚里搭景。我们有点像是在搭起第四面墙来完善那个房间，
because the play all takes place in one room. And so we just completed the room and shot it on a stage in the one room. Your performance was just mind-loyal. It means so much coming from you. Thank you. It was. Not that much, but I really want to see it.
因为整部话剧都发生在同一个房间里。所以我们只是把那个房间给补全了，然后在摄影棚的那个单间里拍摄。你的表演简直让人惊掉下巴。从你口中说出这话对我意义重大。谢谢你。确实如此。虽然没那么夸张，但我真的很想看。
I really, really, really... By the way... It's on Netflix. I'm going to watch it. Are you do have an account? Well, I share it with like 20 people. but I'm going to watch it and then I'm going to get your number from Sean
我真的、真的、真的很想……顺便说一句……网飞上就能看。我打算去看。你难道没有账号吗？好吧，我和大概20个人共用一个账号。但我打算去看，然后我会从肖恩那里拿到你的电话号码，
and I'm going to text Aaron from Kimmel what I thought about. You might be texting Aaron. And I'm going to be honest. Now, Carrie, where are you right now? Are you home or are you traveling? Are you on location somewhere? I'm not home.
然后我会给吉梅尔节目的亚伦发信息，告诉他我的观后感。你可能会给亚伦发短信。而且我会实话实说。那么，凯莉，你现在在哪儿？你在家还是在出差？你在某个外景地吗？我不在家。
I'm on location because we're doing a new YouTube series at my company called the street you grew up on. and it's something I started in pandemic because my production company is named after the street that my mother grew up on in the Bronx, Simpson Street. And when we were kids, we used to hear all these stories about
我在外景地，因为我们公司正在制作一个全新的YouTube系列节目，名叫《你长大的那条街》。这是我在疫情期间开始搞的项目，因为我的制作公司就是以我母亲在布朗克斯长大的那条街——辛普森街（Simpson Street）命名的。当我们还是小孩子的时候，我们经常听到各种各样的故事，
all the shenanigans that went on in Simpson Street. So I feel like that's my once upon a time. Like my grandparents came to the states through Ellis Island. They immigrated from the Caribbean and they lived in the Bronx and Simpson Street was like, you know, where it all started, where the dreams began.
关于辛普森街上发生的那些恶作剧。所以我觉得那就是我的“很久很久以前”。就像我的祖父母通过埃利斯岛来到美国一样。他们从加勒比地区移民过来，住在布朗克斯，而辛普森街就是，你知道的，一切开始的地方，梦想萌芽的地方。
So I interview people that I really like and respect and admire other than the three of you and about the street that they grew up on. How do you have room after the three of us? So, yeah, and I asked them questions about the street they grew up on and what their childhoods were like.
所以我采访那些我真正喜欢、尊重和钦佩的人——除了你们三位之外——聊聊他们长大的那条街。在提及我们三位之后，你怎么好意思接着采访别人？所以，是的，我问他们关于他们长大的那条街的问题，以及他们的童年是什么样的。
That's really cool. It's fun. So we're doing a bunch of them today. You know what I always wanted to do, but you can, by the way, you can have this idea if you like. Eat an entire cart and of ice cream by yourself and then do it again right after?
这真的很酷。挺好玩的。所以我们今天得拍好几个这样的节目。你知道我一直想做什么吗，不过，话说回来，如果你喜欢的话，这个创意你可以拿去用：一个人独自吃完一整车冰淇淋，然后紧接着再吃一整车？
Yeah. And, yes, and. is, is, it's like similar to that idea, which is go visit with a celebrity the places they lived before they made it, right? So like go back to their apartment and knock on the door and interview the family that lived there,
是的，而且，是的，这有点类似于那个创意，那就是去拜访一位名人在他们成名之前住过的地方，对吧？比如回到他们的公寓，敲敲门，采访现在住在那里的一家人，
that lives there now, and kind of swap stories about how you lived when you were there. And I think it would be really cool, all the apartments and whatever. I have a dream about maybe next season going to some of the locations with our guests. Do it, do it, do it. It's incredible.
交流一下你当年住在那儿时的生活故事。我觉得这真的会很酷，所有的公寓还有各种地方。我甚至有个梦想，也许下一季可以和我们的嘉宾一起去一些外景地参观。做吧，做吧，做吧！这太不可思议了。
But think about the stories you'd get from the people that live there. Yeah, the people that live there now. You're like our next Barbara Walters. This is incredible. Wait, so the first question, the first question that I ask everybody is to learn the name of the street that they grew up on. I asked their porn names. So I want to know the name of your first pet and the street you grew up on. So I want to ask you three your porn names.
但你想想从那些现居住户那里能听到多少故事啊。对，就是现在住在那里的人。你简直就是我们的下一个芭芭拉·沃尔特斯。这太不可思议了。等等，所以第一个问题，我问所有人的第一个问题，是了解他们长大的那条街的名字。我问他们的色情片名。所以我想知道你第一只宠物的名字和你长大的那条街。所以我要问你们三个的色情片名。
Not your actual porn names that you have used in the past because I know you have those. So it's the pet's first name and the street you lived on. Your first pet. First pet for me was a little bird that was a cinnamon color, and so he was called Ciney, or she was. And then the first treat was Emerson. Cynie Emerson. There you go.
不是你们过去用过的真正的色情片名，因为我知道你们都有过。规则是：宠物的名字加上你住过的街道。你的第一只宠物。我养的第一只宠物是一只肉桂色的小鸟，所以它叫西妮（Ciney），或者她是。然后第一条街是爱默生（Emerson）。西妮·爱默生。给你。
I like that. That's kind of cute. Sweet little Cine Emerson. That's my middle name. Emerson's my middle name. Cine Emerson receives a lot in these horns. Not a lot of giving. Mostly catching. She's good at it.
我喜欢这个。挺可爱的。可爱的小西妮·爱默生。那是我的中间名。爱默生是我的中间名。西妮·爱默生在这些色情片名里收获颇丰啊。没什么付出。基本全靠接盘。她很擅长这个。
Yep. Can catch his bird? real passive. Will, what about you? We had a cat. You don't have to explain the story. Just what's the name of the first pet in the screen. He got to talk about the stupid fucking bird.
没错。能接住鸟吗？挺被动的。威利，你呢？我们养过一只猫。你不用讲那个故事。直接说第一只宠物的名字和街道就行。非得聊那只蠢鸟干嘛。
And receiving and catching up. You guys are like my kids. He got to do it. It would be Minu Edgar. Minu Edgar. Now Minu Edgar is giving a lot of pain on these porn. Cini sees Mino come. and just starts running.
又是接收又是接盘的。你们俩简直就像我的孩子。他非得说这个。那叫米努·埃德加（Minu Edgar）。现在米努·埃德加在这些色情片名里要付出不少代价了。西妮看到米奴来了，撒腿就跑。
Johnny, what about you? Mine's Josh Valley. Josh Valley. What kind of animals named Josh? Your pet's name was Josh? My dog's name was Josh, and I lived on Valley Avenue. Your dog's name was Josh? Why did you name your dog Josh?
强尼，你呢？我是乔什·瓦利（Josh Valley）。什么动物叫乔什？你宠物的名字叫乔什？我狗的名字叫乔什，我住在瓦利大道（Valley Avenue）。你狗的名字叫乔什？你为什么给狗起名叫乔什？
I didn't name it. My dad did. Oh. Oh, this guy. Now, Kerry, what was yours? Mine. The best was that I interviewed my mom for the series, and I was like, you didn't have any pets, Mom, did you?
不是我起的。是我爸起的。哦。好吧，这家伙。那么，凯莉，你的呢？我的。最好笑的是，我为这个系列节目采访了我妈，我问她：“妈，你以前没养过宠物吧？”
And she said, no, no, we did. We did. we had a cat named Big Boy. So my mom's, my mother's porn name is Big Boy Simpson. It's just the best. That's fantastic. I had hamsters. Yeah, yeah.
她回答说：“不，不，我们养过。我们养过一只叫‘大男孩’（Big Boy）的猫。”所以，我妈的色情片名是“大男孩·辛普森”（Big Boy Simpson）。这简直绝了。太棒了。我养过仓鼠。对，对。
I had hamsters named Trick and Treat. And I grew up on Pugsley Avenue. So Trick and Treat Pugsley. Also, very active. Trick or treat Pugs is. Yeah, yeah. Wow, that's so cool. I love that.
我养过两只仓鼠，分别叫“恶作剧”（Trick）和“款待”（Treat）。我是在帕格斯利大道（Pugsley Avenue）长大的。所以是“不给糖就捣蛋·帕格斯利”（Trick and Treat Pugsley）。而且，也非常活跃，不给糖就捣蛋的帕格斯。对，对。哇，太酷了。我太喜欢了。
And that's how you launch. into that's how we start each episode that's great I love that so in a perfect balance then how often are you working how often are you home like how often do you like to be bored throughout the year because I like I think boredom is the route to relaxation
而这就是你切入……这就是我们每集节目的开场方式，太棒了，我很喜欢。那么从完美平衡的角度来看，你工作的频率是怎样的？在家的频率是怎样的？一年里你喜欢有多少时间处于无聊状态？因为我觉得无聊是通往放松的途径，
if you can try to find you're right but so I'm not very relaxed these days because I haven't been very bored this is the main theme of my therapy these days is figuring out how to schedule more like open creative time because I am a
如果你能试着找到……你说得对，但我这些天可不太放松，因为我一点也不觉得无聊。这成了我最近心理治疗的主要课题——如何安排更多开放式的、有创造力的时间，因为我是一个
doer. Like, I really like to be busy and I like to accomplish things and feel like I'm being productive and useful in the world. But I also really, really love my family and spending time with them and being able to read a book on the beach. I'm with the reading the book on the beach team. I can't do it. Thank you. I do. I'm with that. Or even a listen and an audio book. Sean, what if you were in like in a nice cabana, right? So we've got nice breathable fabric around three sides of you. We've got a nice roof over the top. We've got some sort of a frosty drink. You're in Bermuda
行动派。我真的很喜欢忙碌，喜欢完成任务，喜欢觉得自己在这个世界上很有成效、很有用。但我也真的很爱我的家人，喜欢和他们共度时光，喜欢在海滩上读一读小说。我是“海滩读小说”战队的。我做不到。谢谢你。我能做到。我是那边的。甚至可以听有声书。肖恩，如果你在一个漂亮的凉棚里，怎么样？四周都是那种透气的面料，头顶上有个漂亮的屋顶，手里有一杯冰爽的饮料。你穿着百慕大
shorts and a Hawaiian shirt. I'm going to be thinking, I know what you're asking. Could I read a book then? Yeah, and you got a nice fan on you. Maybe there's even a reportable TV. With the fan that has the missed. Believe me, Sean's never met a fan he didn't like, okay? Sean, that would work, right? Well, let me, I'm going to
短裤和夏威夷衬衫。我猜你会想，我知道你要问什么。那我那时候能读书吗？对，旁边还有个好用的风扇。也许甚至还有一个带雾气的可移动风扇。相信我，肖恩这辈子没见过他不喜欢的风扇，好吗？肖恩，那样总行了吧？好吧，让我……我来
ask you the same question. You know that. But it probably wouldn't because I'd be distracted by the beauty and the breeze. And I'd want to like go do something. You can't sit still. But here's the other thing. But it's not the whole day. It's just like a section of the day
问你同样的问题。你知道的。但那可能还是不行，因为我会被美景和微风分心。我会想去干点别的。你就是坐不住。但还有一件事。但这又不是一整天。这只是那一天的某一小段时间，
where you get to disappear. Carrie, what you need to understand is Sean can't sit still and not fidget and do that and read a book and anywhere. However, I have been with him on a return 14 hours each way flight to L.A. to Istanbul
你可以暂时隐身。凯莉，你需要明白的是，肖恩根本坐不住，无法安安静静地不瞎晃悠、不做那些小动作去读一本书，在任何地方都不行。不过，我和他一起坐过往返各14个小时、从洛杉矶飞往伊斯坦布尔的航班，
where he played Candy Crush the entire fucking time. So he is... I'm listening to the games. So he can just do... By the way, calling that a game is... like fucking, you know, like calling a pamphlet, a book.
他在那架飞机上玩了一整场该死的糖果传奇。所以他……我在听游戏的声音。所以他能直接……话说回来，把那个叫作游戏，简直就像……就像把一本小册子叫作书一样操蛋。
It's just like... Why don't you just rip the door open and jump out somewhere over the Atlantic and just like, how could I still be engaged with this eight hours in? I'll never forget that flight, too, because they fed us 80,000 pounds of food. Like, you just did not stop serving food. Where are you guys sitting up front? I remember eating... Sorry, I remember sleeping, like, for like six hours at one point, and then waking up and being like,
这简直就是……你为什么不直接把舱门拉开，在大西洋上空的某个地方跳下去呢？就像，在八个小时的飞行中，你怎么还能一直玩得这么起劲？我也永远不会忘记那趟航班，因为他们给我们喂了八万磅的食物。就像，他们根本停不下来不送吃的。你们当时是坐在头等舱吗？我记得吃东西……抱歉，我记得有一会儿睡了大约六个小时，然后醒过来，心想：
Oh, man, I really... And looking in Sean, Scott, the same position. Do, do, me, me, me, me, me. Is that your meditation? It is, I get to check out and, like, I love that. Yeah, that's what I'm addicted to is, like, the solace of that. Well, they work hard on that. They work hard all those games to control your brain.
哦，天哪，我真的……然后看到肖恩，天哪，还是保持着同一个姿势。嘟、嘟、米、米、米、米、米。那是你在冥想吗？是的，我可以暂时放空，我太喜欢这个了。对，让我上瘾的就是那种宁静。好吧，他们在那些游戏上花了很多心思，绞尽脑汁来控制你的大脑。
I know. By the way, they can have it, right? Oh, my God, don't worry. Turns out, they claim there wasn't much to grab. They took what they could. They really candy crushed my brain. All right, so listen, we're going to let you go soon, I promise, but I want you to talk about the prophecy podcast.
我懂。话说回来，他们确实做到了，对吧？哦，天哪，别担心。结果证明，他们声称其实没留下多少好感。他们能拿走的都拿走了。他们真的把我的大脑给糖果传奇化了。好了，听着，我们很快就会放你走，我保证，但我想让你聊聊《预言》播客。
What is it? Because it sounds amazing. You're starring in it, your EP on it, and it stars Lawrence Fishburn, Daniel Day Kim, and David Oye Loa. Oh, yeah. I want to, yes. So I also, I want to thank so many of a lot of the folks that I work with wanted me to do this podcast, even more than I were.
那是什么？听起来太棒了。你在里面主演，你还是执行制片人，主演阵容还有劳伦斯·菲什伯恩、金大贤和大卫·奥伊罗。哦，对。我想，是的。所以我也要感谢，和我合作的许多伙伴比我更希望我能做这个播客，甚至超过了我自己的意愿。
I mean, I really, I'm such an Uber fan, But there's a guy on my team name Will who was like, we have a podcast coming out Prophecy. So you, yeah, it's a bad name. He sounds cool. He sounds brilliant. Will was like, because we're doing a podcast, we have to be on the best podcast.
我是说，真的，我是个超级粉丝，但我团队里有个叫威利的家伙说：“我们有个播客要上线了，叫《预言》。”所以你，对，这个名字挺烂的。听起来他挺酷的。听起来他才华横溢。威利当时说：“因为我们要推出播客，就必须上最好的播客节目。”
So that is part of why I'm so happy to be talking to you guys. So Prophecy is, it's a narrative podcast on Audible. It's a really cool concept. The concept is like, what if the Bible wasn't a document about things that people thought happened in the past? but what if it was a prophetic document about things that were going to happen in the future? And so I play this woman, this scientist,
所以这也是为什么我这么高兴能和你们聊天。所以《预言》是一部在Audible上线的叙事广播剧播客。这是一个非常酷的概念。这个概念是：如果《圣经》不是一本记录人们认为过去发生过的事情的文献，
who winds up being pregnant, and I don't know how, because my husband can't impregnate me. We know that. And my name is Virginia Maryland. So like Virgin Mary. And there's a scientist named Jonah who gets in a situation with a whale and stays alive for three days.
而是记录未来将要发生的事情的预言性文献呢？所以我在里面饰演一个女人，一个科学家，
And there's a guy named Daniel, who's a zoologist who winds up in a lion's den and they don't kill him. And it's kind of like these biblical happenings are popping up and what does it mean and how do we deal with it and it's very cool. It's a great idea. It's like sci-fi. And has that yet been optioned? Well, a part of why I wanted to,
她莫名其妙地怀孕了，而我不知道是怎么回事，因为我丈夫让我怀不上孕。我们心知肚明。我的角色名叫弗吉尼亚·马里兰（Virginia Maryland）。听起来就像圣母玛利亚（Virgin Mary）。剧中还有一个科学家叫约拿，他遭遇了鲸鱼事故，却在鱼腹中活了三天。
I'm in this deal with Audible to create podcasts in the narrative space and I feel like it's a really good way to test out story and figure out is this limited, is it a film? I think this one is a film. Sounds like a great show. Are you kidding? That's cool. And is the idea then to like maybe if it goes well to make it a actual series?
还有一个叫丹尼尔的动物学家，他最后掉进了狮子坑里，而狮子却没咬死他。这就像是这些圣经里的事件纷纷在现实中上演了，这意味着什么？我们该如何应对？这非常酷。是个绝妙的主意。这就像是科幻故事。那这个项目已经被买下改编权了吗？嗯，我之所以想要，
Yeah, yeah, or a film. I think it might be a trilogy of films. That's really cool. I would watch that. Yeah, I would watch that. Let me look at my schedule. How long is the shoot? Start, oh, do you want to be in it?
我跟Audible签了协议，要在叙事音频领域创作播客，我觉得这是测试故事可行性的绝佳方式，可以琢磨一下：这是一个限定剧？还是一部电影？我觉得这个很适合拍成电影。听起来是一部很棒的剧。你在开玩笑吗？太酷了。那接下来的打算是，如果进展顺利的话，把它拍成真正的系列剧吗？
Yeah, how do you feel about self-taping, Will? I want to be fucking number one. Carrie, you were talking about number ones? And I'm like, what is she working towards here? And I'm like, oh, here it comes. Here comes the pitch. So the number one's move-b-b-b-b-b-then she pitches this show. It could be a movie, actually, and then she looks right at me, and I'm like, here we go.
对，对，或者拍成电影。我觉得它可能会拍成三部曲电影。真的很酷。我会看的。对，我会看的。让我看看我的档期。拍摄周期有多长？开始，哦，你想参演吗？
All right. So tell me, I'll tell you what. You know I'm at CAA, launched some numbers our way. Can you fucking let me look at the sketch. Give us something to react to. We'll fit it around your golf. You try to shoot around your golf. Yeah, that's true.
对，威利，你对自录试镜感觉如何？我一定要当第一男主角。凯莉，你刚才一直在谈论第一主角？我还在想：她这是在为啥做铺垫呢？然后我想：哦，来了。推销要来了。所以第一主角这套路刚用完——接着她就开始推销这部剧了。它其实可以拍成电影，然后她直勾勾地看着我，我就心想：来咯。
That's a good point. Carrie Washington, you know how much I love you. You got the email. I love you. I love you so much. I think you are incredible. And I'm a massive, massive fan as you all. Can I just say, I want to say, as somebody who, like,
好吧。这样吧，我告诉你。你知道我在CAA（经纪公司），把数据发给我们过目一下。能不能让我看看大纲。给我们点可以互动的素材。我们会围绕你的高尔夫行程来安排拍摄。你尽量配合高尔夫来调整拍摄时间。对，没错。
this is what we do all the time. We have to talk to people. We do these interviews. It's so real. I can tell every time. time I listen that people are they don't want to get off with you they're like they love these interviews it's a good time people are not wanted to get off with jason for a long time oh no she did it that was perfect she's self-bide she's self-bide so good no one has ever self-fied before that was
这倒是个好点子。凯莉·华盛顿，你知道我有多爱你。你收到邮件了。我爱你。我太爱你了。我觉得你棒极了。正如你们所有人所知，我是你的超级、超级粉丝。我只想说，作为一个……
great carry Washington DC oh she had the full district yeah yeah yeah yeah so is carry Washington Not a lot of people know that. So, she's a dream. Carrie Washington would actually be the great name for a, like, just like a detective series, too. Harry Washington, like that's the name of her character. Well, no, no, no, no, but you'd spell it C-A-R-R-R-Y because trying to, like, keep Washington, like, she's carrying what.
我们平时就是这么干的。我们得跟各种人聊天。我们做这些采访。这太真实了。每次我听的时候都能听出来，大家都不想挂断和你的连线，他们都超爱这些采访，这是一段美好的时光。人们已经很久不想跟杰森挂断连线了。哦不，她成功反撩了。这太完美了。她反向调侃了，太棒了。从来没有人这样反向调侃过，
Yeah, she's got to carry one. Oh, my gosh. By the way, let's pitch her. Get her back on. Can you call her back? Yeah, well, Sean doesn't have her number, but email or Sean isn't that the dumbest story Sean that story is so fucking it's so good
真是太棒了，凯莉·华盛顿，哥伦比亚特区。哦，她连地区都带上了，对，对，对，对。所以凯莉·华盛顿……没多少人知道这个。所以，她简直是个梦中情人。凯莉·华盛顿其实也是个很棒的名字，比如适合拍一部侦探剧。哈里·华盛顿（Harry Washington），就像她角色的名字一样。不，不，不，不，但你得拼作 C-A-R-R-Y，因为就像是要“撑起”华盛顿（Carry Washington），就像她在承载着什么。
I mean it's so embarrassing it's so unbrand for you By the way you just made the leap I love that Aaron was on the other end of that Yeah that Aaron Aaron's the other person And obviously Aaron knows the story I think I told her yeah Yeah Aaron Irwin who's the best
对，她得承载一切。天哪。话说回来，我们向她推销一下吧。把她再请回来。你能把她叫回来吗？对，好吧，肖恩没有她的电话，但是可以通过电子邮件或者——肖恩，那不是史上最蠢的故事吗？肖恩，那个故事太该死的好笑了。它太棒了。
It's so good at best Wait a minute what about how great she is And she's so delightful And so smart and so gorgeous and so talented and so real and normal. Yeah. I always say that about every guest of ours. But like, I can't stop.
我是说，这太尴尬了。这完全不符合你的个人品牌。顺便说一句，你刚才提到了那个转折，我太喜欢亚伦当时在电话那头反应了。对，亚伦。亚伦是另一个人。显然亚伦知道这个故事。我想我告诉过她，对。对，亚伦·欧文，他真是最棒的。
That's the thing when you're surprised to me, because we know there's a lot of people in this business in Washington and a lot of other businesses, whatever. You never get like the real them, and that's the real heart. Yeah, you know, I sat with so at that dinner, we talked about that cast dinner, Jay, when you're like, what dinner did you have when you were literally sat across? You literally sat across from Gary.
这就是为什么你让我感到惊讶，因为我们知道在这个行业里，在华盛顿以及很多其他行业，有形形色色的人。你永远无法看到最真实的他们，而那正是最真诚的心。是的，你知道的，我坐在那儿——所以在那个晚宴上，我们谈到了那个演员聚餐，杰，当你在说你坐在谁对面时，你字面意义上就坐在加里对面。
It came back to me eventually. We were jimmies. but we're at Kimmel's and she and I didn't know her at all but she was producing that thing that we've all done and I had the same I had the same reaction I was like man she is so cool and comfortable with who she is and her own skin and so real and you're getting you just had the sense that you were getting this genuine person and she was a delight we laughed a ton she was great yeah she's except for she lied about watching the listen to the dirty liar she admitted yeah she's a dirty liar she should maybe she should do it our are considering the liars, all right?
这最终还是回到了我身上。我们当时是jimmies，但我们在Kimmel的节目里，她和我——我根本不认识她——但她制作了我们都做过的那档节目，我也有同样的反应，我当时想，天哪，她对自己的身份和真实的自我感到多么酷、多么自在，而且那么真实，你会有一种感觉，你遇到的是一个真诚的人，她真是一个开心果，我们笑了无数次，她太棒了——是的，除了她撒谎说听了节目，这个可恶的爱说谎的人，她承认了，是的，她是个可恶的爱说谎的人，也许她应该——考虑到这些骗子，我们是不是也该这么做，好吗？
She's also really funny, like, she should do more comments. She's so funny. Why are we so surprised every time we meet somebody nice and normal in this business? Yeah, because we know too many of the others. But maybe, maybe that's just a vestige of what this business was. Well, it's not just a business. It's just in life. That there are actually a lot of really nice, normal people in this business now.
她也真的很有趣，我是说，她应该多做点评论。她太有趣了。为什么每次在这个圈子里遇到一个既友好又正常的人，我们都会感到这么惊讶？对啊，因为我们见识过太多其他形形色色的人了。但也许，也许这只是这个行业过去遗留下来的一些现象。好吧，这不仅仅是生意，生活里也是如此。现在这个行业里其实有很多非常好、很正常的人。
Yeah. I don't know if it's a thing. It's not necessarily a result of it, but it's maybe it is. there are bad people because maybe it's just a buy product I don't even see it coming, well I didn't even see it coming
是的。我不知道这算不算是一回事。这不一定是它的结果，但也许是的。有坏人是因为也许这只是一个副产品，我甚至没有预料到，嗯，我甚至没有预料到。
product, bay, product, smartless smart smart Mars Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by
产品，湾，产品，聪明，聪明，马，聪明。Smartless 100% 有机，由
Bennett Barbico Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armjarf Smart Less There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本尼特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗伯·阿姆贾夫手工精制而成。Smart Less。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。